what's the best submission in Jiu-Jitsu
a choke I would say from which position
out
if if a billion dollars
to start in a position
like uh in a submission and you only get
the billion if if you get the submission
which one would you start choking them
up Costco not from the back
no you have a better chance gaping from
the back
really yeah even with the hooks even
with everything do you think some people
disagree with you I don't care I have a
better Escape I have a better chance
skating from the back than if you mount
on me put my hands on my neck so I've
been that many you are facing yourself
and I will give you a billion dollars to
escape
you you would uh you would pick from the
back a thousand times over like really
no compare you have like uh with hooks
with like a triangle like that matter
you can do whatever you want but like a
body triangle okay
okay
thousand times over so what no question
says you the amount is a super
controlling position it's not just
because
cross color choking the amount the
moment they put both hands on my neck
you know you have to your arms need to
be very close to your body to attack so
that means there's very little space
between us
so that means there's very little escape
space for you to work on your escape and
the moment that you cannot Bridge let's
suppose I have you know the person has a
good Mouse so he cannot Bridge him off
what else you don't have space to try to
work on your defense being in the back I
have all this space around me to work on
my difference in my arms I have the
mobility to bring them anywhere
so I because of that he gives you me a
much better chance
and you cannot I can move my body if you
feel my back you you cannot pin me
Yuma I cannot take you off my back first
I need to defend the choke but you have
no control over my body so that means
there's still a lot of movement that I
can try to use to escape in the amount
there's no movement I'm pinned down I
cannot move and I have no space between
us to escape well the argument against
that this is great is that on the bottom
of Mount I the uh I do have my hands
between
so you're saying they're pinned there's
nothing between where I mean you could
get them in theory you could somehow you
could but there's no you can but then
there's no space they'll be squeezed
between our bodies if it's an incredible
if it's an incredible amount no it does
not Mount like how standing if I put
both hands on your neck if I'm gonna go
for the cross collar choke after I get
my hands in the next step is to pull you
close to me so it's this my arms needs
to be closer again
put there's the hands that could do
something they can come in but this they
have very limited space between us yes
yes no I mean to push your body away
standing not if your back is against the
floor okay the argument against the
mount is uh or the argument for back
controls being the most dominant
position is even though I have hands I
can't really use them effectively
as effect 9 amount there's no space
there's no space you can try
I mean you can squeeze your hand in I
mean there's there's still things that
you could do but they're so limited so
if you pulled
the 100 best competitors of all time
what do you think they would answer to
that do you think most would agree with
you
I don't care
it's fine it was showed me
their skills the ability to see okay so
the perfect mount versus the perfect
back control there's no question okay
there's no question for me
I mean argue with me like show me
because I'm not being stubborn because
I'm being I've been scientific
so explain it to me why the back it
would be harder it would be better to
your position to finish the amount if if
you can explain it to me why
I might change my mind I was trying to
but uh
I don't I don't have the cred
I'm like a middle school a science
student trying to talk to Einstein here
okay